well can you name all 50 states in  alphabetical order and also name their  capitals well these students at wolf  elementary can they took the great  american challenge and it didn't stop  with that the kids also had to say the  first and last names of all the  presidents listing them in order and  then recite the preamble of the  constitution and the gettysburg address  one fifth grader says she learned a lot  about what it means to be an american  i learned that america it went through  like pretty  hard challenges but i'm proud to be  american after like learning about all  the different challenges it went through  to get to where we are today  well after all that hard work they  retreated to a luncheon and award  ceremony for their accomplishments